stackdriver improves the observability
of our services and helps us put SRV
principles into practice but how can you
try some of these features without
impacting your production monitoring
setup with the stackdriver sandbox you
have a fully instrumented environment
ready to test in minutes I'll show you
how to set it up right now this is the
stack dr the stack traverse sandbox is
an open source project that helps you
learn how to use stack driver it
includes everything you need to get
started it provisions a demo application
composed of multiple micro services and
configures monitoring you can try the
project by visiting its home page at
stackdriver - sandbox dev and The
Associated github repository will put
links to both in the description below
I'm here to show you how to create a
sandbox of your own and use it to try
Statuary features we've covered in
previous episodes start by going to the
sandbox home page from here simply click
on the open and cloud shell button to
open cloud shell and download the
project repository run the install
script in the current directory the
script will take a few minutes to build
and deploy all the components while it's
running
let's review what's happening the script
is creating a new Google Cloud project
within that project it's creating a
kubernetes engine cluster and deploying
the sample application to it finally
it's creating a compute engine virtual
machine that'll be used to generate load
against your application when the script
finishes running it provides you with
four URLs to access the first takes you
to the stack driver interface where you
go through the process of setting up
your workspace you'll need to confirm
the creation of a workspace and add any
other projects you may have to be
monitored as well once the setup is done
you'll be ready to use stackdriver the
second URL take you to the cloud console
for you in your project and the third
URL takes you to the home page for your
sample application running in kubernetes
engine the fourth URL takes you to the
load generation tool use it to simulate
20 users with a hatch rate of 2 which
means that 2 users will be added every
few seconds until we get up to the full
20 now that your application is under
load you can use stack driver to observe
it start by viewing the kubernetes
cluster by selecting kubernetes engine
from the resources menu in the cloud
console you can use this dashboard to
see the performance of your
infrastructure workloads and services
and you can click on each row in a
dashboard to get metrics and logs for
that resource because
this is a distributed application
composed of multiple microservices
understanding service latency is key
click on trace on the left side and then
go to the trace list to see the request
being traced then click on a request to
see how it traverses the services in the
application and latency for each service
call
finally to understand the performance
and resource utilization of your
services themselves go to profiler
select the product catalog service and
CPU time is the metric profiler shows
you CPU utilization down to the method
level and you can use this data to
optimize both service performance and
resource utilization we've built the
stack driver sandbox to give you an
opportunity to try these and other style
features quickly and easily we'll come
back to it in future episodes and use it
to learn about features like error
reporting and debugger thank you for
joining me today
and come back soon for more this is a
stack dr. stay healthy out there
[Music]